I think swim in butter there's got to be
something a little bit wrong with you
because we follow a narrow black line
for four hours a day pretty much every
day of the week and we've got to be
constantly thinking about new areas to
improve and we trained so much that to
keep yourself motivated you've got to
have that extra personality that you've
got to have something a little bit
different about you I never really go
into the pool or the gym with no knives
and effort to be the best in the world
even though from not feeling good I've
got to do something about it and you
know just kind of get the job done so
I've used science and sport probably
since 2014 so four years now this has
probably been the year where I've
started to engage more and my nutrition
because I'm looking for those extra
edges now I use a lot of nutrition
products to kind of get that edge
because I believe that no not a lot of
athletes are getting that kind of best
side of things for me when I'm training
obviously I want to be hydrated but all
the same time I want to be taking a
product that's going to actually help me
I combine the hydration tablets the
lemon ones with the branched chain amino
acids it tastes great
and also I know I'm going to get that
kind of peak performance in my training
session the branch chains to me it gives
me that extra edge to almost recover
mahalo I'm training swimming is just one
of those things where it's got to be on
it the performance you see at the end of
the season or an amazing Championships
is that's just me on that day but all
that work and all that preparation is
years and years of getting ahead of the
curve you know what are they doing and
how can I do that